hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's what i eat in a day youtuber
review is sponsored by spotlight
and we'll be looking at lifestyle
youtuber blair walnuts
now before we get into the review i want
to tell you about this new toothbrush
i've been using by spotlight oral care
i have to admit that in my house we are
pretty obsessed with oral hygiene
and not going for my regular dental
cleanings has been a
serious challenge of covered life
but i got to try some spotlight's
products and i was
really impressed by the results the line
was developed by
two irish dentists using clinically
proven
harm-free ingredients that are vegan
toxin-free
sulfite-free sustainable and perfect for
sensitive teeth
i also love that the packaging is fully
recyclable
so it's really nice for those of us who
are trying to cut back on waste
i've been using their sonic toothbrush
for two weeks now
and already my teeth feel so much
smoother cleaner
and are even starting to look a little
whiter this will definitely come in
handy when baby comes and my coffee
intake gets
out of control no but seriously the
toothbrush is also
really powerful yet gentle on sensitive
gums
and i love that the two minute timer
makes sure that i do a thorough job
and for those looking for even more
whitening action they also have
whitening strips that are also gentle on
sensitive teeth
you can join the spotlight tribe and get
25 off of your first order
by clicking the link below and using my
code abby25
okay so blair is known for following the
diets of famous celebrities like
gigi hadid kendall and kylie jenner as
well as
other youtubers that we've reviewed on
the channel like erica costell
stephanie buttermore and chloe ting when
she's not following other people's diets
blaire shares a variety of vlogs and
what i in the day videos of her
own which we'll be taking a closer look
at today
now before we jump into my review i want
to start with my general disclaimer that
the information in this video
is for entertainment and educational
purposes only and you should always seek
out the help of a medical professional
or registered dietitian for your unique
healthcare needs
also while we do watch an entire work
day's worth of content
we cannot catch a youtuber's entire
catalog
so please keep in mind that what you see
may not fully reflect a full creator's
diet
also a quick reminder to please be kind
in the comments
both here and on blair's channel and on
that note
let's meet blair
hi key excited to make like a smoothie
bowl kind of thing which is like what i
see people on youtube doing i was like
oh my god i'm going to be so cool and so
in and so trendy oh my god hip
tick tock renegade so i shoved it in the
embroidery
and i started blending and boy did it
get liquidy it was more of like a
smoothie
than a smoothie bowl but i'll take it i
mean i was just excited that this thing
worked i was
excited i didn't electrocute myself set
myself on fire like those are all wins
in my book especially when i'm in the
kitchen i don't know if you've seen any
of my other videos but honey i am not a
cook i just pretend to be one
so in addition to her espresso blair has
a bowl of sheep's milk yogurt
with some berries and honey blended into
kind of like a smoothie bowl kind of
thing
love the combo of yogurt and fruit right
there we've got
protein carbs fat and fiber
it's definitely a smaller breakfast
which is fine if you're not super hungry
but a lot of people may want to bump
this up with maybe some nuts or seeds
to give it a little bit more staying
power as for the sheep's milk yogurt
it's actually higher in protein and
calcium than cow's milk yogurt
and more notably it's lower in lactose
so it can be a good alternative if you
are slightly sensitive to regular cow's
milk dairy
but you maybe don't love plant-based
yogurts
she's also got some raw honey in there
which is a super trendy ingredient right
now because
it has more bee pollen in it than
pasteurized honey
and there is some research to suggest
that beet pollen may have some
anti-inflammatory properties
plus about four times more antioxidants
than
the typical squeeze bottle stuff i do
however want to flag that
even though raw honey may contain more
health benefits
the lack of processing may also make it
more prone to the spores
that cause botulism pasteurized honey
can also contain these spores
but the risk is a bit lower than with
raw honey
so as a general rule it's important for
children under the age of one
to completely avoid honey regardless of
whether it's raw or liquid and
pasteurized
okay let's move on to lunch
and what i think is really interesting
about european eastern european
restaurants
is that they kind of all let you smoke
in the restaurant so
all of them have a faint odor of like
cigarette smell
and everywhere you turn someone's
smoking lighting up it's totally normal
here i read a lot of the reviews on
tripadvisor because i use tripadvisor
not yelp here
and a lot of the people were upset about
the cigarette smell i've kind of grown
to like just accept it as part of
eastern europe but i understand if
you're not from here you'd be like um
excuse me like why is everyone smoking
this is disgusting but
i don't know i just got used to it oh
another really interesting thing is all
the restaurants pretty much serve the
exact same like
20 dishes here like you can find the
shopkins lots you can ask
any single restaurant for and they will
all make it for you and they won't look
at you weird
or anything the other thing i got was
steak and french fries because
i just love french fries and mayonnaise
okay leave me alone okay so
here we see blair enjoying a lovely
restaurant meal with her partner in
bulgaria
she has what looks like an aperol spritz
a tomato cucumber and feta salad
and some steak frites as her mane now i
can only assume that she ate it all
because she didn't really show it
but it does look delicious mine is the
april i
personally despise aperol but
of course tell me below if you hate me
for saying that because i do know that
it's a really popular drink
but honestly i'm desperate for a drink
right now and i still wouldn't even want
a sip of that stuff
fries on the other hand i am here for
now while
restaurant meals will inevitably always
contain more calories than they're
made from scratch counterparts at least
this one has some good balance going on
i mean
we've got veggies from the salad we've
got protein and carbs from the steak
we've got some fat
and carbs from the fries are these the
healthiest sources of fats
and carbs and protein no obviously not
but she's on holiday and what i'm happy
to see is that blair is choosing foods
that she enjoys
and it doesn't look like the steak
frites meal is like a catalyst for a
massive cheat day challenge
she also may have been a little bit more
hungry following her lighter breakfast
meal
so it does make sense to choose a
heartier
higher calorie higher fat lunge let's
see what she's having the rest of the
day
so this snack feels super european
and totally makes me want to travel asap
which let's be real
between covid and baby is not going to
happen anytime soon
but anyways we have some carbs from the
bread
we've got fat and protein from the
sausage and cheese
no it's not the avocado toast that we're
used to seeing from most
wellness influencers but it is nice to
see blair being
flexible and eating like a local while
abroad
of course if i put my dietitian hat on
we would want to up the fiber
and balance out the salt and saturated
fat a bit
maybe by adding in some crunchy veg or
some fruit
but i also think it's normal and
expected that our
vegetable intake will be lower on days
that we're traveling
let's finish off with some dinner
i usually make their meals in one pot
because i am really lazy and i hate
doing dishes so you can try that too
they always turn out so
incredibly delicious and they have
vegetarian and also meat eater meals
so i really hope you guys enjoyed
today's video don't forget to click the
link down in the description follow me
on instagram
nut down okay so blair partnered up with
hellofresh to make this vegetarian
mushroom pasta dish which
looks totally delicious and considering
she did have
a protein and meat heavy lunch it
definitely does make sense to go
vegetarian at dinner i am definitely a
big fan of meal delivery kits for
helping busy people to
get a meal on the table and i actually
really like a lot of hellofresh's
options
now with this one she could totally
serve this with like a little side salad
or to keep it one pan she could throw in
some random veggies like cauliflower
or broccoli or bagged greens just to
bump up the veg a little bit in this
meal
like her lunch and snack this meal is
relatively higher in salt
and saturated fat from the cheese so if
you are sensitive to sodium
one little hack that i like to use
sometimes is to go half seas on the
parmesan cheese
and throw in a few tablespoons of
nutritional yeast instead which
would give you that kind of same cheesy
flavor for
a lot less salt let's move on to day two
after making some mountain tea it was
time to make my favorite breakfast
white stuff in a jar this is actually
sheep's milk yogurt i tell you guys
about it in every video so if you don't
know that i
eat yogurt you're probably new here
welcome don't forget to subscribe down
below
i slice up the strawberries try not to
cut my finger even though you guys think
i will inevitably do it soon is it today
is it going to be tomorrow i don't know
stay to find out
next time on the walnuts i put it in
this cute little ice cream bowl i got
from zara home
nick actually used it for beer the other
day because i did not get beer or wine
or shot glasses because i am a really
good housewife and then i make it all
aesthetic and pretty so we could take
cute instagram story pictures because
i'm a professional instagrammer i'm just
kidding i pour in some of my
sweaty shy tea and this is a breakfast
okay so similar to her travel day
breakfast but this time it's
unblended and we have the addition of
nuts so this version
has a little bit more calories and of
course also those healthy fats
now while this is what wellness culture
would call a clean or
healthy meal it seems like it's
genuinely
just what blair enjoys and not something
that she chooses specifically to
eat clean after breakfast she does a
quick
at home workout where she says and i
quote
any exercise is good exercise
yes girl yes you don't need to kill
yourself at berries and lose three
pounds in sweat to make your workout
worth your while
so i love that blaire seems to be
moderate
both in her approach to food and also
movement as well
let's check out her snack this russian
ice cream is the greatest thing i've
ever tasted
russians make their ice cream not very
sweet and not very flavorful
so it tastes like frozen whipped cream
but on the inside there's this like sour
raspberry jam that like adds a little
kick of flavor it's really good and they
don't put too much ice cream it's just
like a little
very communist oh my god this girl i
mean
communist portions aside the way blair
describes this ice cream has me hardcore
craving ice cream right now and i know
you're gonna come after me for not
shaming her for having
ice cream before lunch but honestly it's
just refreshing to see somebody have
a moderate flexible spontaneous approach
to food
she's had a balanced nutrient dense
breakfast fall by a normal size
ice cream cone i mean this isn't a cheat
day this
isn't deprivation this is a girl eating
foods
that she loves in moderation while
listening to her hunger and fullness
cues
and on youtube that is worth some
major love let's move on to lunch
so it's just soy sauce peanuts or peanut
butter
ginger and garlic and that's it that's
it that's the whole sauce
i immersion blended it and there we go
tada
okay so these are my enchilada slash
spring rolls they have
veggies inside on rice paper sheets i
mean not great but not
not just not after that it was time to
show you the mess this made in my
kitchen knife i feel like a lot of
youtubers just completely ignore the
mess
i love how she is keeping it real and
she calls out like
how unrealistic most youtube videos are
this is a true what i eat in a day like
there's no shot lists no filters no hero
b-roll and it's really fun to watch
but okay as for her lunch i do love me a
good
summer roll wrap and actually this
inspired me to put rice paper on my
grocery list
this week because i want to make this
but i also have a whole video on my
favorite
summer roll combinations right here so
definitely check that out
but she's got lots of fiber in the veg
plus protein and healthy fats from the
peanut sauce
and it looks like she threw in some tofu
at the end as well for some plant-based
protein this meal is
relatively low in calories and carbs and
i know she just had an ice cream cone so
maybe she was looking for something
a little lighter and a little fresh but
if she
needed a little bit more staying power
throwing in some
buckwheat noodles or quinoa or mango
might make this a little bit more of a
satiating meal or she could just like
serve it alongside a piece of fruit
keeping it simple let's move on to
dinner
so the tuna pasta is literally just four
or five ingredients and probably what
i'm gonna be eating during the rest of
the quarantine
the vegetables was just me trying to use
up the vegetables i had before they went
bad but this is probably something that
i'm gonna eat for the next two weeks
i talked a lot of [ __ ] about tuna pasta
before especially in the honey boo boo
video because
i didn't get it but now i get it i
didn't film myself making it because i
was thinking tomorrow i could do an
instagram live and we can all
watch how i make it and i can talk to
you guys at the same time i thought that
would be fun
i love how simple accessible and
realistic this meal is especially in
cova times when a lot of us i know
are relying on pantry goods i actually
have a really similar pantry staple tuna
pasta recipe on my blog
using store-bought pesto instead of
tomato sauce so
i'm going to leave a link to that below
so that if you've got lots of tuna
that you're working your way through you
know what to do with it
i also talked about tuna and mercury in
my grackle video right
here but as a recap canned tuna is
relatively low in mercury when compared
to fresh tuna steaks
albacore tuna has about .32 parts per
million of mercury so
adults can consume about one and a half
cans of tuna per week
while light tuna like skipjack or
yellowfin
has about a third of that amount so if
you are a
major canned tuna fan light might be the
way to go
now in blair's tuna pasta we've got some
protein from the tuna
and carbs from the pasta but we could
probably bump up
the veggies and add a little bit more
fat to balance everything out so
some nuts or seeds are great pantry
staples to just kind of throw on top
and while a lot of us maybe don't have a
huge bounty of fresh
veggies right now frozen and canned are
awesome as well in fact studies show
that canned and frozen fruits and
veggies
often have as much nutrition or more
nutrition than
fresh because they're actually picked
and preserved at peak
ripeness so don't feel bad if you're
having a hard time eating foods that
aren't fresh
i just recommend looking for options
that don't have added salt
or sugar in them and saving your produce
budget for things that are
in season aka cheap
let's move on to day three
i poured my oatmeal into a soup bowl and
covered it with salt milk strawberries
butter and peanut butter
it's so creamy and delicious it doesn't
even taste like oatmeal and i also eat
some fruits after
like plums oranges because i really
enjoy a normal bathroom schedule and i
think it's very important to get your
five a day
i'll show you the rest of my day what i
eat and what i do right after a word
from our sponsor okay so
after blair's workout she actually did a
chloe ting
workout which i talked about right here
blair has an oatmeal bowl for breakfast
funny enough she specifically calls out
that this is just a basic oatmeal recipe
with
real accessible ingredients she
basically says she eats
whatever she wants whenever and makes it
simple with the random ingredients that
she already has in her fridge
she says no powders laxatives
ingredients herbs from witches
etc i love that because
nobody's got time for laxatives and
witches herbs in their oatmeal
so anyways you know i love oats because
they're a great source of complex carbs
and soluble fiber to keep you feeling
saturated and fueled for the day
ahead blair also added in some butter
cow's milk and peanut butter
which is going to add in some fat and
protein as well as some strawberries on
top and a plum after breakfast which she
says
helps her keep her on a normal bathroom
schedule
now plums specifically are often used to
relieve
constipation due to their unique
combination of insoluble
fiber plus sorbitol which is a natural
sugar alcohol
that has a natural laxative effect so
plums or
prunes for those who need something more
concentrated are definitely
a good option for keeping things moving
i also love that she said that
she used to not really be into milk but
was feeling it
this particular morning now this isn't a
pro or anti-milk debate here folks so
please
don't comment that below if that's your
mo or that's how you're interpreting
this
that is not even what my comment is
about i just see this as
amazing evidence that blair doesn't eat
by any preconceived food rules or
restrictions
she eats just based on what she's in the
mood for in that particular moment
along with what she has access to on
hand
this is exactly the kind of thing that i
talk about in my intuitive eating series
so
i'm really happy to see that let's see
what blair has for
lunch dinner okay it doesn't look very
appetizing because it's just like rice
vegetables and onions but this is just
what you need for the soup
two eggs three carrots some chives you
don't really need this this is just a
garnish this is one of the easiest to
make
most delicious and most filling soups i
have ever done in my entire life
okay so for her lunch slash dinner
liner dunch i don't know what we should
call it but
blair prepares a lemony greek soup with
some chicken
eggs rice and veggies she talked about
how she's a big proponent of
using and eating whatever she has in the
fridge which again
i think just speaks to her flexibility
and accessibility
as a lifestyle youtuber i also love the
way blair describes this soup
she uses words like easy delicious
healthy
fun not the typical clean or detoxifying
that most influencers are obsessed with
this soup has protein from the eggs and
chicken
veg from the carrots and onions and some
carbs from the rice
i didn't see her use any fat in the pan
and the chicken did look
admittedly a little anemic so i do think
that there is some room for a little bit
more fat in this meal
and even some more carbs and veg if we
wanted to maybe serve this with
some bread and a salad on the side
that might be a little bit more
satisfying than having
three bowls of the soup which would
probably make a lot of people feel
a little bloated from the salt i'm also
not sure what happened in her day to
result in just
two meals but i would think that it
would be pretty uncomfortable for a lot
of people to eat
three bowls of soup in one sitting
that's a lot of water volume so while it
may temporarily make you feel
full maybe even uncomfortably full from
the water
and salt you'll probably start to feel
hunger creep up
later on and that can be really tricky
if you're feeling hungry
but you also feel a little bloated and
uncomfortable at the same time
so i would say that taking the time to
sit down to an
additional midday meal or even a
substantial
fast snack earlier on in the day might
allow for more comfortable portions
by the time that dinner comes lastly
let's take a look at i'm going dessert
start on my nightly ice cream
now i like all sorts of ice cream oreo
ice cream chocolate ice cream i just
don't like vanilla ice cream because i
don't like to be vanilla
and boring but i did have this new ice
cream today which is strawberries and
cream and it was
very delicious i also noticed i eat my
ice cream like a serial killer
very rhythmically precisely and in a
circle like am i okay
i think not but i'm sure if i ate like
another bowl of soup i would have eaten
less ice cream ice cream is more fun to
eat and i like to just eat what i like
to eat
and i don't force myself to eat things
just because they're healthy and today i
felt like having three desserts after
dinner and that's what i did and
nobody not even jesus or the police can
stop me from having three desserts
walnut reporting i just realized i ate
an entire bag of popcorn
and forgot to drink water all day which
is probably the reason i just ate a
bunch of sweets and
like had four desserts
um so i would like to call jesus and
ask him to turn this water into wine
because i don't really want water right
now i want wine so
okay so she's totally right no one not
the police not jesus
not abby sharp can stop anyone from
choosing to have
three desserts if they feel like it and
no i'm not comparing myself to jesus or
the police for that matter definitely
not
i'm just rolling with her joke here but
honestly i know that this is
a lot of fun food but this actually does
seem
to be intuitive to me blair had a
particularly
light day of eating and i don't think
that it was planned that way
i mean sometimes we just have really
busy days and
we don't hear our hunger cues as clearly
as usual
so we skip meals and by the time that we
sit down
and relax we are ravenous so if blaire
were to force herself to eat a fourth
bowl of soup in an effort to curtail her
desire for dessert
i would actually argue that that
wouldn't be as intuitive
as having three post-dinner snacks so
while blair had a pack of oreo ice cream
a serving of strawberry ice cream and a
bag of popcorn
i have a feeling that she was just
responding to the hunger
that had kind of mounted over the day of
not eating to her needs
not only did she maybe forget to eat
enough during the day but she also
seemed to forget to drink enough
water which she said is probably one of
the reasons why she was
so ravenous for sweets now nutrition
wise of course
this snack sesh is high in sugar
saturated fat
and salt there's no question it's also
very likely
based on my professional experience as a
dietitian that having more fuel spaced
out throughout the day
wouldn't have left blair needing to have
three bowls of the same soup at dinner
and still hungry for three desserts
afterwards
she may have been satiated after just
one bowl of soup
or one dessert but blaire was simply
responding
to her body's cues when she had the
opportunity
to actually listen to them and not
surprisingly
her body is asking for more food even if
that food
isn't the most nutritionally balanced
sure i could tell blair to have
one ice cream with maybe a piece of
peanut butter toast and an
egg or a yogurt parfait like she did for
breakfast on day two
that would certainly be a lot more
balanced of a snack
that would probably feel better to most
people who are watching
but the important thing is is that blair
didn't judge herself
for these snack choices she knew that
she was just unusually hungry because
the decisions that she made earlier on
in the day
and she just moved on that's awesome a
lot of people critique intuitive eating
thinking that it's
just this meal right here eating
desserts
just because you want to but it's not
it's a journey
it's a process that involves collecting
data
every single day data that will inform
your future decisions
if you choose to let it so perhaps blair
would take
this day and say to herself hey i got
busy
i forgot to have lunch i forgot to drink
water and the result was that i ended up
eating three bowls of soup
and then still being hungry and eating
three desserts
maybe this felt fine to her i mean she's
a lot younger than me
but over time this pattern of eating
might start to impact
digestion energy blood sugars and more
and it probably wouldn't feel so good
being an intuitive eater doesn't mean
that you always perfectly listen to your
hunger and satiety cues
or that you always respond to the data
that you've gathered
but what it does mean is that whatever
happens
you move on you give yourself permission
to eat
however you have to eat in the
circumstances
without guilt shame or further
restriction
you say hey i let myself get too hungry
and thirsty
and i ate three desserts whatever
tomorrow is another
delicious day my sense is that
blaire just inherently gets this and
that's
more important to me to see than how
balanced her bedtime snack was one day
so let's move on to our big questions in
general
is this way of eating balanced well i
really love blair's easy going and
relaxed approach to food
she eats based on what she likes and
what she has in the fridge
and what makes her feel good in that
moment she also doesn't seem to follow
any strict food rules or restrictions
and isn't concerned about eating healthy
all the time which
is always really refreshing right now on
youtube
in one video where she tried to make
chrissy teigen's famous banana bread
and epically failed she goes on to say
that
eating banana bread is not a big deal it
will not make you gain weight
and that nothing bad will happen other
than maybe
you'll make banana bread every day and
then there will be a worldwide banana
shortage
and that would be bad news bears for
someone we know so
needless to say i love her laid back
approach to food
with that said from a nutrition
perspective there are a few gaps that i
think we want to address
now depending on the day blair is
typically consuming between
2000 and 2200 calories a day which would
be aligned with her caloric needs
with the exception of day two which was
a little skimpy at
1300 calories now i can make a big stink
about this but
i want you to know that it's completely
normal to not eat the exact same amount
of food every day
if you're eating intuitively so it's
expected that the total number of
calories that we consume
may fluctuate day to day based on our
hunger cues
stress levels physical activity sleep
etc
maybe she ate like one of our cheat day
youtubers the day before so her body was
kind of recalibrating
or maybe she was just really busy that
day and the next day when she had more
time
she caught up and ate more unfortunately
i don't have access to her daily food
log but
based on the attitude i see from her
videos
i think there's a good chance that blair
would just kind of let her body
take the lead now when it comes to her
total macronutrient intake
she's consuming a moderate carb and
protein diet
with some days getting a higher
proportion of calories from fat
this is likely because some days she's
consuming almost double the recommended
saturated fat intake from foods like
steak
ice cream and cheese which may or may
not be a problem for
health i did a whole video on the
controversial research on saturated fat
but to summarize some research says that
it may increase risk factors of heart
disease
and other research claims that has no
effect on health
at all but as dietitians because the
research on saturated fat
is so inconclusive we still like to err
on the side of caution and aim for
greater intakes of healthy unsaturated
fats
and complex carbohydrates instead which
do have
demonstrated benefits on heart health
this includes foods like
nuts seeds avocado fatty fish and olive
oil for fats
and whole grains sweet potatoes and
berries for carbs for example
so for me it's less about cutting high
fat foods out of the diet
and instead focusing on what we can add
in
the rest often works itself out and on
the topic of adding more complex carbs
this would also help blare me her fiber
needs since on some days
she's only getting between 14 and 16
grams which is below the 25 gram minimum
recommendation so that might mean adding
a little bit more fruit at breakfast and
snacks
veggies with her meals and some whole
grains throughout the day
i did hear her say that she tries to eat
her you know four or five servings of
fruit a day to keep her regular
so even though i didn't see much aside
from that breakfast
i have to just assume that no two days
are alike for blair
and it's possible that these aren't
really good examples of her usual
routine
i also know that we're in quarantine
which can make getting fresh fruit and
veggies
a little more challenging but like i
said there's nothing wrong with throwing
in some frozen canned or even dried
fruit and veg
lastly blair had also mentioned in one
of her videos that her iron levels are
low
and that she's anemic and therefore
needs to eat a lot of meat
and spinach totally fair anemia is no
joke and
even with the meat in there our analysis
suggests that blair's intake
is still below the 18 milligram
recommendation
for people who menstruate it's actually
somewhere between 8
and 12 milligrams per day so if she
wants to upper intake without the
saturated fat found in a lot of red meat
she could also add in more tofu or lean
poultry
which we did see in her diet so that's
great plus some lentils beans
pumpkin seeds baked potatoes or dried
apricots
for the plant-based sources she can
maximize the iron absorption of these
foods by pairing it with a source of
vitamin c
so an example of this could be something
like a trail mix with pumpkin seeds
and dried berries for a balanced snack
or maybe lentil soup with a lot of lemon
and squash in there or maybe a stir fry
with some tofu
and bell peppers and broccoli now are
there any problematic claims or
assumptions made by this channel
as i mentioned earlier blair is known
for trying out people's diets
usually showing some kind of weight loss
results and giving her overall opinion
on the specific diet blaire will often
title her videos like how to be skinny
or a skinny legend
or how to lose weight fast which is
usually paired with
a before and after weight loss photo in
the thumbnail at first glance
this combination of weight loss imagery
and seemingly
positive appraisal of being skinny like
some
famous celebrity seems to just
perpetuate diet culture
fat phobia and even some disordered
eating behaviors
however if you actually watch enough of
blair
and i've been watching because this girl
is really entertaining
you'll actually start to pick up on the
satirical
nature of her content it's kind of like
those
jp sears videos that poke fun at
wellness culture trends like
youtubers going on vegan when you
actually
watch her and the moments of realism in
her videos
you'll see some evidence of her true
thoughts for example
in her video on gigi hadid's diet after
weighing herself before the diet
she literally says that weight does not
matter
and it's just a number like your social
security number or your street number
she also often talks about how eating
something like the banana bread
won't cause bad things to happen or that
she's just eating intuitively when she
chooses something
that diet culture would deem as bad so
this tells me
that even though she is trialling a diet
that's intended purposes by the original
creator
was for weight loss blair isn't doing it
to lose weight she's making a sassy
cultural statement
about the sensationalism of these
outrageous
unsustainable and unbalanced diets that
we often find online
it's not unlike what i do but from the
perspective of a viewer
like you who might be tempted to try it
rather than from a nutritional
professional
having said that of course if you're
just watching a blair walnut's video
here or there
or you're looking at her click bait pro
skinny titles
i can see why it can be confusing or
even triggering to some viewers
now from my perspective after watching
blair's own what i in a day videos
it doesn't look like she herself follows
any of these restrictive
or carefully controlled diets if she did
i would think that she wouldn't have the
emotional flexibility to be able to jump
into each of these insane challenges
without panicking
what the impact would be of eating an
excess or in a deficit for a single day
she's smart she knows it's just for
funsies
and that her body will kind of figure
itself out in the days to follow
i actually think that it takes someone
with a really strong faith in their body
and a weight neutral mentality to be
able to kind of waffle between some of
these outrageous youtuber
and celebrity diets and then to eat
moderately on their own
now aside from following people's diets
blaire has also tried some popular
fad diets like intermittent fasting and
the keto diet
in her video on intermittent fasting
where she followed the diet of tick-tock
star dixie dimelio
she lists the benefits of intermittent
fasting including weight loss
blood sugar regulation brain functioning
skin health
reductions in inflammation and risk of
diabetes while i do appreciate blair
highlighting that intermittent fasting
is
not just about weight loss since that is
the primary narrative in the media
whether or not all of these claims of
blares are evidence-based
is up for debate i know you guys want me
to do a whole video on instrument
fasting and
i do need to because there is a lot to
cover
but let me quickly summarize based on
these quick claims that she made
yes there is some research to support
the health claims of intermittent
fasting
but the problem is that a lot of these
claims are based on
animal studies and really short-term
studies so
we do need more long-term studies to
confirm its benefits
and the sustainability for long-term
weight loss for example
a 2016 review showed that while most
individuals following intermittent
fasting
did lose weight most of the weight
happened really early on in the study
and plateaued around the six-month mark
with the rate of any subsequent weight
loss
slowing down around the one to two year
mark
there is also some research to support
the benefits of intermittent fasting for
inflammation
as well as blood sugar management so
that's not untrue
as for the benefits of intermittent
fasting and cognitive functions
well animal studies and anecdotal
reports have shown promising results
similar to what blair experienced for
herself
when she said that it enhanced her mood
however we
don't have a lot of strong human
evidence to back this one up yet
another popular fad diet that blair
tried on her channel
was keto which happened to be sponsored
by aikido app
now normally i would totally call that
out as shady like i did with alyssa
when she did this quick shift from
veganism to carnivore
in line with her butcher box sponsor but
because trialing these popular diets is
kind of blair's format
and she didn't claim that she was going
to do keto for life
i guess it makes a little bit more sense
anyways
in this video she ate some pretty
nutritionally dense meals like
shakshuka for breakfast salmon and
radishes for lunch
and some chicken and asparagus for
dinner this is a far
cry from the cheese on bacon on beef
diet
that we often see characterized as keto
online so
i am glad that she was able to find a
version of the diet
that felt good to her what i liked about
this diet experiment
is that she used a lot of positive
language when describing food
and the keto diet in general for
instance she talked about liking salmon
because it has
more texture and flavor which makes it
extra yummy
and that the keto diet helped her to
feel really satiated so that she didn't
feel the need to snack as much
this impact on appetite on the keto diet
is actually quite common
as studies have shown that ketosis can
suppress the hunger hormone ghrelin
causing a reduction in appetite so this
could explain why some people feel like
they have success on keto
because fat is just inherently very
satiating
as for the benefits of the keto diet
blaire mentions that while the keto diet
can promote weight loss
it can also lower cholesterol improve
blood sugar levels
and regulate appetite and blood pressure
if you missed my older video on keto you
can definitely check it out right here
but in short i would say that these
claims about the keto diet that blair
mentions
are largely supported by the literature
when it comes to heart health
the research on keto is a little bit
mixed
some research suggests that over time
the keto diet may have
a negative impact on cholesterol levels
while other research has found
improvements in cholesterol levels and
other risk factors for heart disease
like blood pressure
studies have also found that keto may
help to lower blood sugar levels
in people with insulin resistance and
type 2 diabetes but
that it's not of course appropriate for
people with type 1 diabetes
due to the risk of hypoglycemia having
said
all of that these diets are not benign
both come with serious risks and while
it may be fun to play along for a day or
a week
it gives us no information how well one
might do
or fare in the long run and we know that
for the vast majority of people
any restrictive diet is typically poorly
sustained
so since blair's content seems to be
about entertainment anyway
i would say that if she's going to touch
on the alleged benefits
of a diet that she's trying out i also
think it's only fair that she also
outlines
the potential risks and who it may not
be for
finally what can we take away that we
love about blair's channel
well i think blair is super entertaining
and hilarious to watch so
i can totally understand the popularity
of her channel
when it comes to her actual recipes i
appreciate that unlike a lot of
lifestyle vloggers
blair's recipes are really realistic
really accessible
and definitely not deliberately
instagramable
she eats what she has on hand and what
she likes and that varies from day to
day which
is so refreshing to see she also seems
to be morally neutral when it comes to
weight
and food and while she may play the
typical
diet debbie following along with the
latest food fads in her real life
she doesn't seem to follow any of these
crazy restrictive food rules that she
mocks on the daily bottom line if you're
looking for some fun
really hilarious youtube content
definitely consider blair's channel
of course her channel may not be for
everyone especially
if weight loss language and imagery is
triggering for you
or if you're easily offended by
satirical humor
but overall her content is pretty
light-hearted
fun and more of a mockery on dye culture
than an endorsement of it so i'm all for
poking fun at die culture in a hilarious
way so
kudos to blair for finding a clever way
to do just that
and that is all for today folks a big
thank you again to spotlight for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
any youtuber that you want me to review
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you